hello my name is marile lapata i am
from the school of informatics at the
university of edinburgh and today i will
be talking about automatic movie
analysis and summarization via turning
point identification
and do not worry if you don't know what
turning points are by the end of the
talk you will all be very familiar with
them
okay before going into the details of
the talk i want to introduce my
collaborators uh penelope papa lmpd is a
graduate student at the university of
edinburgh and
she has mostly contributed to the
research you will be hearing about the
turning point identification
but aside from penelope there are three
other people that have helped um
form the ideas in this talk leah
freerman philip gorinsky and frank
keller leah and philippe are no longer
at the university of edinburgh sadly but
still very valued collaborators
okay
so let me start with a question
statement
who doesn't like movies
everybody loves movies
some people love making them others love
watching them and if you are michael
dana here
you may
think that we love films and
storytelling as a people
and in fact michael dana goes on further
to tell us that it is just a human
compulsion to listen to and tell stories
so according to him the fact that we
like watching movies is in our genes
and i forgot to say that michael dana is
a canadian um composer so he composes
course for movies and here he's picking
up his award and is telling us that
movies are in our genes now because
movies are in our genes movies are
indeed everywhere so here's a couple of
statistics that i gathered for this talk
with regards to the content shared at
this point by netflix and amazon and i
mean there is others as well but let's
look at those two so netflix has
currently 67 000 movies series and shows
you can watch all of them if you have a
netflix subscription
amazon is even worse they have 24 000
movies and 2
100 shows to choose from
the average person watches three point
half hours of television
per day
so
um people watch a lot of television
and there is a lot of content that these
providers want to share with us
now
the problem is that there is too much
content
so the average household has three
streaming services so you may have
disney plus amazon and netflix for
example or apple tv and disney players
on amazon and any permutation of those
you may like
now the polled users this likewise inc
is a company and they did a poll um
among american users and they asked them
um do you actually can you find
something to watch given that everybody
has so many streaming services and 75 70
of the users of the viewers agreed that
they often struggle to figure out what
to watch and this is staggering this is
like a big number
and apparently and viewers need more
than 15 minutes to decide what to watch
so and you add that on top of your
average marvel movie which is i don't
know three hours so this is a lot of
time spent deciding what to watch let
alone them going and watching the movies
okay so we come in here and we want to
help these viewers and we want to make
them happy you see now this happy family
that uses our technology to watch movies
so how can we help these poor users
these poor viewers
for example
viewers may want alternative trailers
or they may not bond trailers they may
want a movie summary that summarizes an
entire marvel movie in 10 minutes
and another idea that another another
thing that viewers may want is not to
have a summary but to have some zooming
function that tells them what are the
important
shots in the movie and this is highly
personalized some viewers may want
action-packed shots others may want um
scenes with female leads or if you like
comedies you may want to see all the
funny shots or the happy scenes
okay and so now we are moving from
actually having content that is the same
for everyone to highly personalized
content
and we want to help these viewers and
you will see how we may be helping them
throughout the talk
okay so um
of course there has been some previous
work on analyzing the content of movies
and this is not surprising movies are
cultural artifacts but also are
considered text and they are also
considered a form of literature
so there have been two types of
approaches in the past
they only focus on texts
that means they only process the
screenplay
and for example you can look at
characters and create networks that tell
you how the characters evolve through
the movie or you may want to take the
screenplay which is like a book
screenplays are very long they're
approximately 150
pages and you take the screenplay and
you extract the scenes to create a
summary this is another idea
but of course you cannot watch this it's
just a written summary
um so this is one approach one class of
previous work and the other approach
focuses only on the video
and in particular not entirely movies i
don't know why they just look at
isolated video clips and they try to
analyze them
and now we will depart from both of
these approaches in that we will be
looking
at the multimodal space so we will take
a movie and a movie for our purposes is
the screenplay
as well as the video
we will also try to
process
the entire movie so we will we aim at
creating a summary based on the full
length of the movie
and the important point is that we will
do that based on turning point
identification
so to repeat we will
look at a movie from beginning to end we
will look at the audio video and text
the screenplay as well and our goal is
to be able to summarize this so that i
take a five hour long movie and i'll
play you a 10 minute summary how am i
gonna do this we're gonna do this by
this idea of identifying turning points
okay so before i tell you about turning
points and what they are and how we will
use them in making summaries let me just
briefly summarize why this movie
analysis and movie summarization what we
wanted to help users is a very
challenging task
now the videos
as you know the movies are long
on average they're two hours and they
are not only long most of the time if
you're watching a good movie it's a
complex story
so in order to summarize this you really
need to understand what's happening what
are the main events in the movie
the
field has used some heuristics to be
able to create summaries in particular
if you look at summarizing news
documents because in the news there is a
well known conventions that for example
the most important bits of information
are going to appear on top of the news
article so if you extract these on top
of the news article you will you will
create a more or less good enough
summary this is not the case with movies
not all of the information appears in
the beginning it's interspersed
throughout so these position biases and
it will not work
and also if you try to identify
importance heuristics or diversity
heuristics which people have done
for other types of summarization again
the task is so complex that all of these
heuristics fail
so there is a problem of the
understanding and then there is a second
problem which is uh as important and as
challenging which is the fact that um if
you want to have a machine learning
model to
learn how to produce these summaries
this is a very challenging task because
there is no annotated data available and
so
for news one may find summaries the
people who write the news also sometimes
write the summaries and they publish
them and we can get them and we can
collect data to actually train a model
for movies this is not the case
there are no
labels available that will tell you this
scene is important or it is not or this
shot is important or is it not of course
you can go and create this but this will
be a huge effort and it will never be
enough
so we have to be creative we have to
think of models that actually can handle
this data positive issue
um
so
what can we do about these challenges
our hypothesis here is that a movie
summary consists of scenes
that act as turning points
so if you look at the screenplay a
screenplay is naturally uh segmented
into scenes these are
different
locations or different things that
happen in the movie and we know them if
we look at the screenplay so our
hypothesis is that um different scenes
asked at act as different turning points
now of course i haven't told you what
turning points are
so let me begin by uh
telling you that turning points are
actually a very very old idea um it goes
back to aristotle who you see here
in all his glory
aristotle um was very much preoccupied
about
how one tells stories and he came up
with this triangle telling us that every
story consists of three main thematic
units these are and this is the famous
triangle you start with a protesters
this is uh introductory material then
things happen more events accumulate you
have the epitasis which is the climax
the most important events in the story
and then you sort of
start having resolutions until you end
up with a catastrophe which is the end
of the story now this is what aristotle
said and here we have freytag
a few centuries later who
takes this aristotle triangle and turns
it into a pyramid and she says well the
triangle is a bit naive here i have a
pyramid so there is more
more events happening and i have the
exposition which is the beginning then
there is some inciting force
action rises i have my climax so he kept
the climax then falling action some
resolution and the end now frederick is
important because the modern theory of
turning points is really based on this
pyramid
so what are turning points finally
turning points are narrative moments
they determine the progression of the
plot so what happens from one point to
the next without the turning points
there is no progression and they segment
the narrative into thematic units and
this is important once we have like this
moment in time and there is a turning
point
the
plot will change it will progress into
another direction
and in this work we adopt a modern
scheme that has been put forward by
hague
in a book written in 2017 and i should
point out that these turning points are
the bread and butter of
screenwriters in particular in hollywood
and i forgot to say whatever i'm talking
about is how people do movies in
hollywood once i was giving another talk
and i was asked about bollywood and
i don't know uh chances are though that
most people have some turning points in
their movies so here's the uh modern
version you see on the screen of what
turning points look like and these are
the definitions that i will be using
throughout this talk so there is a setup
in the setup we have introduction of
characters and then something happens
there is an opportunity first turning
point
the opportunity because the turning
points progress the plot um
brings us into a new situation while
we're in the new situation there is a
change of plans plans have changed and
there is some progress in that direction
at which point we reach the point of no
return so both the hero the protagonist
and
co-protagonists are committed to a goal
there will be complications and a major
setback and while i'm talking this i
want you to
remember movies that you've seen and you
liked most movies follow this narrative
structure after the major setback there
will be the final push you either
overcome the setback or not there is a
climax and the movie ends
now i know this is a bit abstract so in
the next slide we're going to see
an example and as an example we will use
the shining the shining is a
psychological horror film
that was released in 1980 and was
produced and directed by stanley kubrick
and in fact it is based on a book
written by stephen king now when the
shining appeared in the theaters
opinion was divided some people liked it
some people didn't like it stephen king
himself came and said oh it doesn't
follow my book i don't think it's great
anyway the point is the shining has
become a classic
and it is a beautiful illustration of
turning points okay so in the next
couple of slides i will show you exactly
where the turning points are in the
movie the shining and apologies if you
have not seen it and you wanted to see
it because it will contain some spoilers
the only thing that can get a bit trying
up here during the winter is a
tremendous sense of isolation
well that
just happens to be exactly what i'm
looking for i'm
i'm outlining a new writing project and
five months of peace is just what i want
okay
so we've seen here this is the first
turning point which is the opportunity
and it's an introductory event that
occurs after the presentation of the
setting and the background of the main
characters so we see here jack nicholson
he's the main character
and he is given an opportunity to go up
in a hotel that is somewhere in the
mountains to be the
caretaker
during the winter months where
there is isolation and he says that you
know it's great
a little bit of isolation is fantastic
because they have a writing project he
wants to write a book and this would
seem fine so after the opportunity
we have
the change of plans well
maybe things that happen the other kind
of traces behind
not things that anyone can notice
but things that people who shine
can see so here we
the change of plans
is an important event it defines the
main goal of the story
and from this point on the action begins
to increase and you see there is this
dialogue there is this child this is
jack nicholson's child and um the notion
of the shining
is explained so the shining is is some
people have this shining and they can
see observe things that aren't
observable to everybody else and it
turns out later on in the movie we see
that this child has this shining
charisma
okay then we move on
so this is the point of no return
it's an event that pushes the main
characters to fully commit to their goal
and here um
jack nicholson tells his wife i dreamed
that i killed you and danny so this is
his goal now remember this is a horror
movie to kill his family
here's johnny
so now this is the major setback um
so
the main character the protagonist has
committed to his goal which is to kill
the family and
from now on he's trying to achieve this
goal and the setback is where everything
falls apart so he's trying to kill them
but of course they're resisting and he
he has to overcome that
[Music]
so this is the final turning point
called the climax it's
the moment of resolution if you like and
the biggest spoiler here we see
jack nicholson frozen maybe i can play
this again
[Music]
so he tries to kill his family but they
managed to resist and in the end we see
him frozen in the
um in the snow so he he did not manage
to do this
okay
now let me explain how we will use these
turning points to perform
uh summarization so like i mentioned
before we have the screenplay we have
the video and we have the audio we have
like these three modalities which we
will use to predict
in the movie the turning points much as
you've seen that i've done already with
the shining so we have to go in the
movie and identify
which scenes are representative of
turning points and like i said there's
five turning points so we will identify
five scenes
algorithmically we will have a model to
do this and then we will collate these
scenes and create a video summary which
we can play to the users and make them
happy
okay
so
we model movies as far as graphs
uh obviously we have to have some way of
representing these movies to be able to
learn uh later on to predict the turning
points so we will adopt a
graph theoretic interpretation of movies
where nodes are scenes and the edges
denote similarity between scenes
and we argue here that the graphs are
actually quite important because they
contextualize the scenes and they reveal
complex interactions between events
for example
movies are not linear
there's flashbacks and so on and we
assume here that the graphs will be able
to represent that and also because uh we
take a movie and we turn it into a graph
we believe that it will be more
interpretable in particular if we
sparsify the graph and we only
sort of keep the important notes
okay
so i'll give you a sketch of the model
without going into too much detail so we
have from the screenplay the scenes
and we can obtain representations from
for these scenes and you can use uh
whichever neural network model
takes your fancy it can be uh birds it
can be barred so it can be
t45 anything you like it can be an lstm
so we have these representations of
scenes
and starting from those now we have to
build our graph
and the way we do it is we take all the
scenes that are the nodes it's in the
graph and we compute the pairwise
similarity and how we do this is we
measure similarity as a combination of
textual similarity based on the
screenplay but also an audio-visual
similarity so we want to take all the
modalities into account and so we create
a complete graph
um
where the
edges have weights
and the weights you know the similarity
between nodes which in our case are
scenes now because screenplays have very
many scenes they can have
it depends it varies from movie to movie
some movies have only 50 scenes other
can have 100 or 150 so these graphs tend
to be actually really big
so we specify them to highlight
important notes
and we do this by learning a sparse
graph in an end-to-end model and in
particular we learn what are the most
important
neighbors for a given node and and
select the top k ones and this is the
graph specification stage so once we
have sparsified the graph
then we take this representation
and
learn a graph convolutional network on
top of this graph
in addition to this we also take our
scenes
that are represented in any way you like
and we also learn their content by
running a bi-directional lstm so we have
the graph and i have the bi-directional
lstm
and
i have two types of representation a
more global representation if you like
that is afforded by the graph and the
more
content-based one afforded by the
bialystem i concatenate these two
representations
and
i feed them to a classifier that will
predict will give me the probability of
a scene being one of my five turning
points and i do this for every scene in
my screenplay so for everything in the
end of the day i will have the
probability of it being turning point
one two three four or five and then i
will select the scenes with the highest
probabilities and concatenate them
together and i will output my video
summary
okay let me give you some more specifics
before showing you some results um so um
this model that i presented was trained
on a data set that we created it's
called tripod it contains 122 movies uh
approximately 18 000 scenes
and um 1 600 turning points so we
actually had to go and annotate the
turning points ourselves uh people when
they write screenplays they don't say
i'm going to have a turning point here
and a turning point there and a turning
point afterward this is a way of writing
the story but they are nowhere indicated
and it turns out that people actually
agree pretty much when they have to find
these turning points
so we use this data set
that we created because we have to be
able to predict the turning points and
actually see if we're correct or not and
we created graphs that we specified so
every movie was represented by a graph
and we kept up to six neighbors per node
per scene in a movie graph
and the way i'm gonna produce the
summary is i will assume that
every turning point is represented by
three scenes a sequence of three scenes
and if you do that you have five turning
points so approximately you end up with
a ten minute summary and it was the same
compression rate for all the movies we
looked at
okay one final word on evaluation and
then i will show you some results and
what you can do with these graphs so
there's three ways of evaluating um
these output turning points
assuming you have some gold standard
turning points that we have
we had to create to be able to evaluate
and one is total agreement which is the
percentage of turning point scenes that
are correctly identified now this is a
very harsh metric it turns out even
humans don't have perfect total
agreement we have very many scenes and
we have to identify one correct
um so a sort of more representative
metric is partial agreement and this is
the percentage of the turning points for
which at least one gold standard scene
is identified
so
the algorithm will go and identify
five um scenes for telling point one if
one of these is a gold standard scene
then this is good we count it as a hit
and the third metric which is also quite
informative is distance so we measure
the minimum distance in the number of
scenes between predicted and gold
scenes for a given turning point and of
course we normalized by screenplay
length so partial agreement higher is
better
distance
lower is better which means that you
know we predict a scene as a turning
point and it's quite close to the gold
standard scene
all right so now let me tell you um
let me give you uh
some idea of the results um so and the
first
set of results focuses on turning point
identification because if we can't
identify turning points there is no
summary
so
here i'm showing you the two metrics
partial agreement higher is better
distance lower is better for two
baselines the first one is um
random so we have the scenes and we
randomly select scenes and we have hope
for the best we're hoping that we're
gonna hit a turning point the second
baseline i call it position bias but
what it does is it takes into account
some of the heuristics that people have
in hollywood when writing screenplays in
particular um
there is this rule of thumb that you
know the opportunity has to happen 20
in major setback has to happen by the by
half of the movie and so on and so we
take these uh heuristics and we create
this position by us and you see that
it's doing better
in terms of partial agreement but not so
good on in terms of distance then the
next set of results are tech string and
sin sum these are both graph based
models but do not have any notion of
turning points or of events that take
place in a movie so track strength is a
very well known and supervised graph
based algorithm and
it has been used to perform
summarization in nlp and it basically
creates a graph notes in the graph are
seams in our case and it identifies um
in terms of outgoing and in-going edges
uh the most important scenes and this is
our summary symson is another
graph-based algorithm that um
centers uh on around the notion of a
character this according to some uh
other schools of thought in hollywood
movies are nothing but characters so
here we identify characters in the movie
we built this graph of characters and
accordingly we i identify the most
important scenes and again you see that
even though these
algorithms have no notion of turning
points they do better than random and
position bias
now tam stands for topic aware model and
this is a model that knows something
about turning points it again tries to
identify them but has no graph structure
so this is a sequential model that
basically is sliding a window you can
think of it as a
supervised text segmentation algorithm
that slides a window along the
screenplay and i
measures the similarity between
different windows and
decides whether to insert a boundary i.e
a turning point and finally we have this
graph turning point which is the model i
presented to you and you can see that in
terms of partial agreement the graph tp
model
does best and also it is
does better than
the topic aware model in terms of
distance even though the the difference
here is is
less
now
this is how we identify the turning
points what happens with regards to the
summaries are they any good
so
here
we i will present you the results of a
human evaluation where we actually
played
summaries created by these various
algorithms to humans so they watch them
and then we ask them do the summaries
contain the key events and by key events
we explain to them what turning points
are and they have to say
does this summary contain turning point
one turning point two three and so on
and we also ask them are the summaries
over informative do you understand
what's going on in this movie
and
i only show you three models here
simpson which is a graph based model
based on characters no turning points
tam is topic aware model
which is based on which has some notion
of turning points but no graph graph tp
is the model represented here which
knows something about graphs and turning
points and finally gold these are the
gold standard summaries that we have
and
we want of course to be approaching gold
and as you will see here the graph based
the graph tp which is the orange model
is doing pretty well it manages to
beat comparison systems
for all turning points
and it is almost as close to gold with
regards to the first turning point the
same for the second turning point
turning point three um is difficult it's
not so surprising this is uh the change
of plans uh turning point four it's
doing quite well 10.5
it's
not doing so well this is the major
setback this is difficult and finally
it's the resolution
so overall we see that
the orange
dark orange is our model is uh much
better than the comparison systems and
in some instances even
approaches the gold standard so this is
all quite
encouraging uh but this is not a lead
i
we actually claim that
the graph is not only useful to predict
the turning points more accurately but
it's also important because it gives us
insight as to
the semantics of the movies and what
makes them different different so
the last part of the talk i will show
you examples of what these graphs mean
so
we
take these graphs that we create and we
pre improve them to be able to inspect
them
and we only keep turning points and
their immediate neighbors and then we
measure the node connectivity so
how much is given node is connected to
all other nodes
of the
sparse graph
and we also have grouped the movies into
four broad genre categories to be able
to do this analysis
and now i'm showing you the node
connectivity per turning point
for
comedies and romance movies
and you will see that a node
connectivity is quite high 0.8 this
means that for these movies comedies and
romance movies
and action movies we start with uh fully
con with with rather well connected
graphs that means that uh you know every
character is connected to every other
character and all of them um
do things together and the story is
relatively coherent
now contrast this to what happens to
thrilleries to thrillers mysteries and
drama
so you see here that the graphs are less
connected so they have low connectivity
which indicates that the storylines are
more complex
and also the graphs are are more uh
detached
okay so
let's see some specific examples here
there are comedies and action movies and
there's six in this slide and for
example the wedding date i know nothing
about this movie but you see the graph
is like rather fully connected
uh the same for die hard which is an
action movie total recall and so on
so by looking at this graph we can
immediately say okay the stories are
quite coherent there's high degrees of
connectivity here and contrast these
with dramas and thrillers we immediately
see that the graphs are more
disconnected
let's take panic room
there is
almost like four different things that
happen um
the same with american beauty this movie
has a very much non-linear structure
and you see this is reflected in the
disconnected graph and in general this
makes sense for thrillers because not
everything is revealed in the beginning
we there may be new characters and in
general the stories are more complex um
because of course there has to be
something unexpected in the movie
okay
so uh that's me
uh i thought rather than actually uh
recapping what i've said so far i will
show you the
turning points as identified by our
algorithm for the shining
um
but before i do that let me just say
three things
i've argued that movie summarization can
be done by turning point identification
the movies are represented by multimodal
sparse graphs and these graphs
importantly are interpretable where the
model connections between events can
reveal different properties and
semantics of movies now in the future we
want to
concentrate on actually generating
trailers based on shots but this is very
much future work and without further ado
i will show you the turning points for
the shining as identified by our model
thank
don't want you
please
no
you know doc when something happens if
you leave a trace of itself behind
say like
if someone burns toast
well
maybe things that happen the other kind
of traces behind
not things that anyone can notice
but things that people who shine can see
[Music]
um
[Music]
stop it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wendy
i'm home